[Music]
in complete 180 news submitted by a come
visit Down Under
oh yeah a woman ditched her 15-year
vegan diet and now she eats only meat
Wow one extreme to the other I love it I
read for a week straight though I taught
this to my mom why my mom
well she's vegetarian so but anytime
like we go to a place and then they go
there's your noodles have any like meat
in it and a lot of times they don't even
know so they'll say oh no this one will
make sure we don't cook it with me but
the broth has held a meat in it the
minute she eats it she has to go to the
bathroom entirely be the bacteria the
fat like all of that that your body's
not why in Asia they probably don't have
that many people with our shoes because
they just die mm-hmm
what do you mean could you go to the
restaurant and then you're like I'm
allergic to peanuts like that not being
math and then people yes this woman her
name is Nicole she's 44 this is what she
currently looks like of course I like I
like when they take pictures like that
like look at what I can do it's pretty
funny it's not the theme where like you
look out and got a punch someone
yep yeah I think it could be anything
you know what's so funny about that
simple thing I read this headline that
said like they weren't calling it a
white supremacist yeah we've been doing
it since I was a little ass kid control
man [ __ ] me up every time he'd be like
AHA that's itchy and then I'd look at
him and he would just stop no it was
because like I think some some all right
group was doing it like in their group
photo with their friends they just kind
of it's a 4chan troll though I know that
thing is a 4chan troll but now they've
associated mainstream media has
associated with that movement cuz like
the big trick where they trick the media
all the time with it yeah they even got
the meeting to think that like clowns
are now an all right thing it's so
[ __ ] ridiculous yeah all right anyway
back to Nicole here so she went vegan
when she was 18 years old thinking it
was the best thing for
health and to protect the environment
and so she would just eat whole foods
like leafy green berries vegetables
though she grew her own vegetables and
she cut out sugar alcohol um but then
her health started deteriorating
she suffered joint pain anxiety
depression low energy and saamiya
constipation and you know alcohol they
just the problems she was eventually
diagnosed with ulcerative colitis in
September 2012 like when people try to
do something healthy and it gets worse
for them friend who did like this crazy
cleanse that a worm came out of her ass
and she's like never again no [ __ ] low
is it a coffee
was it a coffee enema it was one of
those like I'm only drinking lemon water
things wait so if I don't [ __ ] know
was in there somehow wasn't organic oh
yeah yeah it was pretty crazy dude cuz I
saw it oh she showed to you she kept it
yeah that's why I came up with the Steve
green rule what is that not pissing and
[ __ ] in front of each other I was
like you never began with this [ __ ]
ain't gonna be the same was it'll I
don't know no it was [ __ ] it was a
living thing it had ribs red ridges like
I said ribs there was one time I thought
I had a worm and then I went to the ER
cuz I'm like what the [ __ ] but it wasn't
it was like [ __ ] idiot
you don't have where I'm stuck then the
[ __ ] doctor comes in he goes have you
been to a third-world country am I know
you gotta talk about the nurse Rose
[ __ ] [ __ ] alright so then she's like
well
we went today right they take all your
vitals and I'm like oh and I'm already
embarrassed right because it's just
disgusting to say that and I'm like what
are you bears about I don't know
so anyway I'm like well I looked at my
poop and there's this thing that kind of
looks like a worm and then she goes dude
you come in here with you with like a
bandage on it she's like okay I hope
it's not a lot of blood cuz I really
don't do a good dude
yes then the doctor comes and he goes
okay we've been a third-world country
I'm like no he's like do you eat garbage
out of her I'm a trash can I'm like I
like no he's like I guarantee you you
don't have worms
he's like are you a ratchet [ __ ] he's
like have you ever been in a gangbang I
think he's just trying to point out how
hard it is to get a worm so the fact
that your ex-girlfriend got it that's
the [ __ ] why I got worse when I was a
kid maybe she had this weird thing okay
feces yeah that you didn't I miss my
ex-girlfriend pirate yoga shoes the high
school with you someone in this room
worms like tapeworm like that yeah yeah
yeah yep
no it was something else it was little
worms Oh what like magnets yeah I told
this story before when my parents had to
put vinegar up my [ __ ] you know this
story but I didn't know cat poop out of
stranding her she was my dogs all the
time they did [ __ ] play you had a
string no I was just asking you can
[Applause]
I'll say yes now can I hear your story
now you know sometimes I see hair yeah
multiple times yeah is it maybe it's
stuck on your book that's something
maybe it's stuck there from like the
cats or something oh yeah stuck in my
butt crack I like sitting cuz my
roommate has a lot of hair and maybe
like I just I don't know but I've seen
it a lot yeah hair like you know you're
you're shampooing and then the hair will
travel from my back and I guess it just
gets stuck in my butt's then I just have
to get it out there I'm not [ __ ] it
out do you naked sit in your foot in
your home in your boxers okay the other
men maybe not you're talking about
[ __ ] hair or like you see it in the
toilet
you see it in the toilet you're eating
there's a place that I used to go to but
I found hair isn't it twice and now I
don't go there anymore so maybe it's
some [ __ ] like that
it's not killing you I don't know if
it's Thai food is just this
establishment but it could be there's a
place that you go to in k-town that's
giving you something that's got hair in
it so when you [ __ ] it was the hair on
the [ __ ] or was it like a [ __ ] nunchuck
it was kind of just like [ __ ] had a hair
like on the pot oh they made like a
hairy mole yeah like like a Cynthia like
Angelica's doll like just kind of like a
Raggedy on top of the turd no it was
just stuck in your butt yeah that makes
more sense that makes me feel good yeah
me feel good back to Nicole here so she
was saying that since she had that since
she was diagnosed with her bowels being
inflamed she came across this
controversial carnivore diet and she
read how it improved a lot of people's
health
some people with autoimmune diseases
they do only yeah so she switched over
from being fully vegan for 15 years to
fully eating red meat so now she's
saying that for breakfast she'll eat a
pound and a half
or no she'll have a pound and a half a
red meat in a date so I'm like that's a
lot of me lunch is one pound of meat
usually steak and that she'll have this
around 12 p.m. and it's her first proper
meal of the day
for dinner she'll have half a pound of
meat which she occasionally adds eggs
and bacon and throughout the whole day
or for breakfast she has coffee with
cream and then throughout the whole day
she's drinking water coffee and
sparkling water and she's just saying
that now all of her she was also having
candida overgrowth because she thinks
she has that what is that that is a grip
so it's like it's a fungi in the body
that can lead to various health issues
when it's out in troll including crazy
bloating or thrush in the vagina like
crazy [ __ ] I don't know Nikki Nikki
doesn't have that thrush yeah brush
she doesn't have room for it cuz she's
too tight you know I'm saying like like
like too much yeast I guess I don't know
exactly it's a fungi they're saying and
so we get new boards get thrush right
they can get in the mouth it looks white
yeah he didn't in a baby's mouth but um
so yeah so then she's saying that she
had candida overgrowth hair loss joint
pain fatigue insomnia and then so she
was saying that her blood test showed
almost non-existent levels of iron and
vitamin D and she was hypoglycemic which
means you have low growth low blood
sugar I'm a vegan days right yeah
exactly what food pyramids mean dude
Binger what to mean it was funded by the
milk industry oh you've been fettled as
was I public school kids got the most
[ __ ] we got [ __ ] so let me show you
more photos so she say she also lost ten
pounds without changing her exercise
from when she was vegan to being fully
carnivore that's cool yes this is when
she was vegan hey she looks even better
Oh delicious
I was bombed
that's burnt dude what the [ __ ] yeah she
doesn't know how to cook but surely
she's online I would not eat that steak
that looked like she killed those eggs
though they go soft boiled eggs are
[ __ ] good just [ __ ] eat plastic
Jesus Christ
you know if she's only gonna eat like
meat or protein - she has to eat organs
because that's where a lot of the
micronutrients are yeah Wow
yeah no like I mean that's that's why I
think you know a lot of Asians build a
taste for fats cartilage and things like
that because all those they're I mean
they're good essentially they're good
for you but that's another source of way
that we're lacking those nutritions
because if we just get the lean meats
we're not getting enough it's just go
time with you because you've introduced
me to some organ stuff but like all that
stuff heart's like Ryan got me into
chicken hearts and [ __ ] and liver but I
lose me every time at [ __ ] chicken
feet and hooves yeah what is with that
hooves is fat and Clark that's what's
good about it yeah you'd like doing
texture you do a soup yeah yeah we'll
pick pig feet pig feet yeah yes I love
it see when I see it I just can't get
into it yeah it takes some time I mean
he's got try like five times a game of
thrones anything over ten years but it
got way to the good no like sour and
good really sour oh I like that pink
well in Arkansas that would be like Joe
right yeah it just looks so into minute
I've heard it's good with beer like you
drink beer and you buy it on to that and
yeah that's why they always have it at
the bar but the way I eat it is in this
Vietnamese soup called boomba way it's
like a pozole or like a menudo menudo
it's like that but then it's it's just
spicy and then they have a pig foot in
there mm-hmm now used to be like hold
the pig head yeah the blood to that [ __ ]
I got used to all of that
but usually does that mean it's good or
used to it that's good no it's good you
develop like a taste for it yeah you
develop it because in the beginning same
thing I was just like give me all meat
like beef and I don't want whatever else
is in there and then eventually you take
a bite and you keep trying it and then
you get used to it same with the chicken
fee like I didn't grow up eating that
stuff and every time it came out I would
look at my Chinese friends as if they're
like barbarians on my [ __ ] disgusting
right and then I just kept trying and
trying and now I could eat it with love
[Music]